-Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am your host,
Midlife Crisis Teen Wolf.
[ Laughter ]
Man, the '80s were
such a different time.
Back then,
inflation was out of control,
there was a cold war
with Russia,
and everyone was worried
that the President was too old.
Weren't -- Those are --
Let's get to some news here.
Apparently,
in a private conversation,
President Biden
told the Reverend Al Sharpton
that he's going to run again
in 2024.
[ Audience oohs ]
Meanwhile, today
Kamala Harris was like,
"Uh, Joe, anything you'd
like to privately tell me?
I mean, hello."
Yeah, that information
wasn't supposed to get out.
Then Sharpton was like,
"He also told me that his
AOL password is grapenuts46."
[ Laughter ]
"Exclamation point."
Yeah, it sounds like Biden
is gonna run again.
He was like, "It's time
to capitalize
on my 42% approval rating."
Yeah, that's right.
Get this --
former president Trump
is claiming that CNN
is trying to hurt his image
ahead of the 2024 election,
and he announced
a $475-million defamation
lawsuit against the network.
[ Laughter ]
In response, CNN was like,
"Hey, thanks for thinking
we have that kind of money.
That's, uh -- Wow.
We pay Anderson Cooper
in Panera bucks.
You know what I mean?"
Meanwhile I read that Trump
is thinking about running mates
for 2024,
and he's considering
his former press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
as well as South Carolina
senator Tim Scott.
But trump wants to keep
his options open, so he just
sent out a questionnaire
for anyone interested.
We got ahold
of the questionnaire.
-Really?
-Take a look at this.
First it says...
[ Laughter ]
Next it asked...
Just by thinking it.
The next question is...
And finally...
And that's -- So if you --
Hopefully he'll find someone
and they'll get it together.
I'm sure he'll find someone.
Well, here's some big news.
After months of trying
to back out of the deal,
Elon Musk just told Twitter
that he's now ready
to buy the company
for his original offer
of $44 billion.
To break it down
in Twitter terms,
the deal was followed, blocked,
then unblocked, okay?
[ Laughter ]
After the news broke, Twitter
stock jumped more than 20%.
When they heard that,
Twitter was like,
"In that case,
we're backing out of the deal.
I mean, we're --
we're doing well."
Well, everyone's
talking about this --
I heard that Tom Brady
and Gisele Bundchen
have hired divorce lawyers.
[ Audience awws ]
Even crazier, Brady first
broke the news to Al Sharpton.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
I saw that Snoop Dogg
is launching a THC version
of Funyuns.
[ Cheers and laughter ]
It's a great idea.
Hopefully this will finally
get stoners to eat Funyuns.
We have a great show.
It's a total '80s show tonight.